[Música]
naciones unidas- corroboró que en lo que
va de la guerra en ucrania hay mil 335
víctimas de ellas 861 son personas
lesionadas y
474 fallecidas incluyendo 29 niños la
onu advierte que los civiles son los más
afectados mientras continúan las
evacuaciones
y la onu también elevó a 2 millones la
cifra de refugiados
organizaciones como save the children
advierten que un millón de ellos son
niños solos por lo que piden más
acompañamiento y apoyo psicológico para
ellos
y la presión de rusia sigue a través de
sanciones eeuu y reino unido- vetaron
las importaciones de petróleo ruso lo va
a idear aseguró que es un paso más fácil
para ellos pues dependen menos del crudo
del kremlin que los europeos pero que
eso no significa una división
un cordial saludo aquí están las
noticias de ucrania en francés 24 400 74
civiles se murieron por la invasión
rusia a ucrania según la organización de
naciones unidas que advierte que ésta
podría ser sólo una fracción de la cifra
real en la última jornada aparecieron 27
civiles en un nuevo bombardeo ruso a
harkov las autoridades ucranianas
estiman que 170 personas fueron víctimas
mortales en esta ciudad la segunda más
grande de ucrania desde que empezó la
invasión el 24 de febrero
entretanto al menos 3.500 personas
escaparon de la ciudad de schumi en el
norte gracias a un corredor humanitario
pactado en los diálogos entre las partes
que tienen lugar en belarús a lo largo y
ancho de ucrania los hospitales están
saturados
este joven acaba de ser sacado de los
escombros sus dos manos fueron vendadas
su cara aún se ve negra por el polvo
todos los pasillos del hospital de
harkov están llenos de heridos que
sobrevivieron los bombardeos de las
fuerzas rusas
esta mujer aún en estado de shock no se
recupera
desde fuera ya estábamos escondidos en
el garaje cuando nos bombardearon me
golpearon en la cabeza
los heridos pertenecen a las zonas
residenciales de jarkko que desde hace
días son atacadas por el ejército ruso
la segunda ciudad más grande de ucrania
quedó prácticamente irreconocible tras
los bombardeos este hombre busca sus
pertenencias entre los escombros
las lágrimas corren por mis mejillas y
eso que soy un antiguo soldado ayer mi
esposa fue herida por una bomba ahora
está en el hospital la han salvado con
dificultades lisa
los trabajadores del hospital también
luchan por contener sus emociones ante
el constante flujo de nuevas llegadas
climático que 184 repostó para
todos los pacientes que aún pueden
caminar quieren volver con sus familias
los que ya no pueden caminar se quedan
aquí
y muy útil y
por desgracia ya no podemos contarlos a
veces hay calma a veces estamos
desbordados
según el último balance de la onu más de
800 civiles han resultado heridos desde
que comenzó la invasión rusa hace casi 2
semanas
el alto comisionado para los refugiados
de naciones unidas de filippo grandi
anunció que más de dos millones de
personas han huido de ucrania desde el
inicio de la guerra entre ellos un
millón son niños informe de rafael pérez
y dejar todo atrás para salvar la vida
esta es la realidad de más de 2 millones
de personas que han abandonado ucrania
en medio de la invasión rusa
antes de la guerra mi entonces novio y
yo nos estábamos preparando para la boda
que estaba programada para el 27 de
febrero pero sucedió que acordamos y
logramos casarnos el 24 el primer día de
la guerra ese mismo día me fui porque
kiev eran muy inseguridades
lydia una mujer embarazada fue acogida
en el sur de francia junto a otro grupo
de ucranianos
en primer lugar espero esto termine
pronto en segundo lugar en mi opinión
personal el presidente de la federación
de rusia realmente está perdiendo la
cabeza su hijo es parte del millón de
infantes que según la ong save the
children salieron del país huyendo a las
bombas la organización puntualizó que
muchos son menores de 14 años enviados
solos ante la imposibilidad de sus
parientes de salir del país
natalia hizo el viaje inverso la
ucraniana radicada en el reino unido fue
a rescatar a su hija ya su hermana pero
no pudo entrar al regreso con sus
parientes porque ellas no tenían
permisos su hija no pudo terminar la
escuela
antes de que empezara la guerra ya había
rumores de que podía haber un
enfrentamiento llamé a mi hija y le dije
hija ven con nosotros me dijo mamá me
faltan 30 días de estudios como puedo
dejar todo y marcharme al día siguiente
comenzó la guerra a la venganza de sueño
la portavoz del comité internacional de
la cruz roja enfatizó que la situación
en ucrania era apocalíptica mientras que
la oficina de derechos humanos de las
naciones unidas ha verificado hasta el
momento mil 335 víctimas incluidos
474 muertos y 861 heridos desde el
inicio del conflicto el pasado 24 de
febrero
sigue la presión a través de sanciones
eeuu y reino unido- vetaron las
importaciones de petróleo ruso yo bailé
aseguró que es un paso más fácil para
ellos ya que dependen menos del crudo
que los europeos
alva santana tiene los detalles
es oficial después de varias amenazas
estados unidos y reino unido han vetado
la importación de gas petróleo y carbón
de rusia que aplicará a partir de
finales de 2022 un redoble de sanciones
que tendrá consecuencias en los mercados
mundiales
este es un paso que estamos dando para
infligir más dolor a putin pero también
habrá un costo aquí en eeuu dije que
sería sincero con el pueblo
estadounidense desde el principio y
cuando hablé por primera vez de esto
dije que defender la libertad nos va a
costar
y es que esta es una medida arriesgada
para castigar a rusia ya que el país
proporcionó más de 700 mil barriles de
crudo a eeuu el año pasado debido al
conflicto y otras variables como la alta
inflación ahora el precio de la gasolina
en el país norteamericano ha batido un
récord 4,1 dólares el galón un precio
que no alcanzaba desde la crisis de 2008
está exageradamente caro cada día más
caro especialmente para los estudiantes
como cada vez es más difícil
permitírselo vamos a tener que compartir
auto
pero europa decidió no sumarse a estas
sanciones ya que el continente es muy
dependiente del gas y del petróleo ruso
allí los efectos de la guerra ya se
están empezando a sentir con el precio
de la energía disparado a 345 euros el
gas por megavatio la hora la unión
europea podría imponer sanciones
energéticas a rusia pero sufrirían
acordemente para los europeos la parte
del pastel energético de rusia es mucho
mayor que aquí en eeuu nosotros estamos
cerca de la independencia energética
pero la eurozona no está ni de lejos a
pesar de las consecuencias globales
desde estados unidos aseguran que
occidente no financiará la guerra de
rusia y que el gasoducto nord stream 2
de rusia alemán ya está muerto previo a
este anuncio el sábado pasado una
delegación de eeuu viajó a venezuela
para negociar con nicolás maduró una
alternativa del crudo de rusia y hoy
tres días después el gobierno venezolano
liberó a dos ciudadanos estadounidenses
previamente nuestra corresponsal en
caracas a daniela zambrano nos amplió la
información se trata de gustavo cárdenas
era uno de los exdirectivos de circo la
filial de pedevesa en eeuu que se
encontraba detenido en venezuela junto a
otros cinco compañeros desde el año 2017
en febrero de este año se había
ratificado la condena de estos
directivos se les impusieron penas entre
8 y 10 años de cárcel y tal y como lo
decías luego de este encuentro el pasado
sábado entre representantes del gobierno
de joe biden y de nicolás maduró junto a
jorge rodríguez y la primera más cilia
flórez pues se conoce esta liberación no
es la única se habla también de que
estaría siendo liberado también jorge
alberto fernández un turista cubano
americano que fue detenido en venezuela
en febrero de 2021 por portar un dron en
el estado táchira y se le había acusado
de terrorismo también una acción
inmediata luego esta reunión fue el
anuncio de nicolás maduró de reanudar el
diálogo con la oposición en mexico por
lo no queda duda que estos pasos que
está dando nicolás maduró es producto de
esas negociaciones entre ambos gobiernos
y se podría esperar no sólo próximas
liberaciones sino también otras
concesiones por parte del gobierno
venezolano que es hayan sido pedidos por
el gobierno de eeuu a cambio de que
pueda venezuela ayudar con el suministro
de crudo luego de que eeuu decidiera
imponer sanciones en esta materia rusia
y más empresas multinacionales
suspendieron sus actividades en rusia en
protesta por la invasión cocacola para
la venta de sus productos y dijo que su
negocio en rusia y ucrania contribuyó
entre el 1% y el 2 por ciento de los
ingresos operativos netos de la compañía
en 2021
mcdonald's y starbucks son otras marcas
que anunciaron su castigo y ordenaron el
cierre temporal de cientos de
restaurantes en rusia
siga con nosotros en france 24
[Música]